-Congratulations on
the success of the show.
We had Chrissy Metz --
Your co-star was here last week.
-Love her.
And we were just
talking about --
And I wonder
what it´s like for you.
Obviously, you started
shooting the show last year.
You had shot a bunch of episodes
before any of us saw it.
-Right.
-So it was not
the giant hit it is now.
Has your life changed
shooting Season 2,
versus how it was Season 1?
-Well, I mean,
I´m sitting here next to you.
-That´s true.
We would have had
no interest in having you here.
-No, no, no.
No, it was less than zero.
Yeah. No, no. It has.
You know, so, we had
this trailer that came out
at the beginning of the series,
and a bunch of people
sort of took to the trailer.
-Mm-hmm.
-So, we kind of knew
there was interest there,
but it hadn´t aired yet,
and it was just the trailer.
It was a
2-minute thing or whatever.
And then the
show started gaining momentum,
and it just kept
going and going and going.
And now we´re into Season 2.
And we´ve had
this long sort of --
this hiatus, where everyone
has been, you know,
missing the show and
wanting the show to come back.
So there´s been that buildup.
And now we finally
came back last week,
and the ratings were better
than ever, thank goodness.
-Yeah, congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I will tell you --
on just the scope and the reach
of your show, I did a cameo.
I played myself,
a cameo in one of the episodes.
-It was one of
my favorite moments.
-Thank you very much.
-Yeah. No, it was.
-I stumbled on you and --
Kevin and Randall fighting.
And I can tell you
I got more calls and e-mails
from friends about that
than I ever do about this.
Like, people genuinely said,
"You were so good in
´This Is Us.´
Are you doing anything else?"
-Oh, that´s great. That´s great.
I get the same kind of thing.
You know, I did
a sci-fi show for a while,
and there was
that fan base out there
that just watches sci-fi shows.
And, so, they´ll say to me --
They´ll be like, "Oh, my God!
Green Arrow from ´Smallville.´
What? Did you just quit acting?"
And I´m like -- I don´t even
know what to say.
I´m like, "Yeah, I´m done.
I quit."
-That´s better.
They don´t want to see
where Green Arrow is now.
"No arrows?!
You don´t have any arrows."
-Yeah, exactly. Just tears.
-But, so, we did
this cameo together.
That was the first time we met.
It was lovely to
hang out with you.
But then I did not realize
we had been in a movie.
This is true.
We had been in
a movie before together,
but we did not
have any scenes together.
It was called "Spring
Breakdown."
Rachel Dratch wrote it.
And we both played
love interests of her.
-Yeah.
-You played the hunky guy
she meets on spring break --
shirt off, looking rad.
And I, her very dear friend, was
cast as her gay fiancé.
So, that is me.
-That´s great. That´s great.
-You know, when she called
and said I won a part,
I just assumed
I´d be a shirt-off hunk,
and she went a different way.
-She went a different way.
-We can´t get away
from each other.
-You got to work with
Sylvester Stallone.
-Yeah.
-How was that?
-I mean, it´s everything you
could possibly imagine
times ten.
It is -- I mean, I grew up
watching his movies.
-Yep.
-I´ve wanted to be Rocky.
And, for a moment in my life, I
think I thought I was Rocky.
-Sure.
-And then there he is.
I worked out with him
at the gym a few times.
We go to the same gym.
How cool is that?
And then Milo knows him
and sort of made a phone call.
And he came.
And graciously accepted
to do the role.
And he´s on set, and here he is,
Sylvester Stallone.
And you´re like,
"How am I supposed to work
with this guy, a legend?"
And he immediately disarms you.
He immediately, like,
puts everybody at ease.
And he´s just, like,
the coolest guy in the world,
and you´re just
having a conversation.
And then he does a bang-up job,
is a wonderful actor.
says a few gracious words,
tells a few jokes,
and then he leaves,
and as soon as he leaves,
you´re like, "Oh!"
You missed him.
You were like, "Oh!
Come back, Sly! Come back!"
-You didn´t know
how good you had it.
-He´s the real deal, man.
He´s the real -- It´s amazing.
-That´s really exciting.
You have a 13-year-old daughter.
-I do.
-And is she a fan of the show?
Is this correct?
-Uh-huh. Yeah, yeah.
-Is this exciting for you?
Is this the first time
she has liked
a piece of your work like this?
-Yeah. I mean, kind of.
I think she --
No, not liked,
but I think it´s the first time
it was, like, cool.
-Sure.
´Cause you´re on a hit show
that, probably, I´m assuming a
lot of her friends watch.
-I mean, the parent-teacher
stuff is great.
You know, going to
the school is great.
I´m allowed to go to
the school now, which is great.
-That´s nice.
-Yeah, ´cause I was on a --
Yeah, I was on a --
It was a hiatus for
a year or two, and now I´m back.
-Just, yeah,
wait in the parking lot,
and now you can actually walk --
-Yeah, she´s like, "You´re,
like, as cool as a 13-year-old."
And I was like,
"Well, thank you."
-Whoa!
-What a compliment.
-That is high praise.
-Life goals right there, man.
Life goals.
-You go to
a lot of Dodgers games.
Congratulations
on making the postseason.
-Thank you. Thank you.
No, I bleed blue.
I´m a diehard,
lifelong Dodger fan.
I have been since I was a kid.
My dad was a big Dodger fan
when we were growing up.
So, I was the only
kid in Chicago
that was, like, a Dodger fan.
People would see the blue hat,
and then I´d turn around.
They´d be like, "Boo!"
You know?
And, so --
-Optimistic? Hopeful?
How do you feel?
-I´m hopeful
and optimistic every year.
We stumbled a little bit going
into the playoffs,
but I feel like
that builds character
and I feel like --
You know, they don´t need
any pep talks, obviously.
They´ve got some great pitching
and they´ve got
a lot of great players,
a lot of energy,
and they´re good as a team
when they play well together,
and they can do it.
And I´m feeling good
about this year.
-I think they would take that
as a pretty good pep talk.
I like that you did that
sort of back-door thing,
where you said,
"This isn´t a pep talk,"
but then you gave a pep talk.
-That´s right.
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you can´t just
go right at it.
They´d be like, "Why are
we listening to this guy?"
But the way you said it, I
think they were like,
"Hey, what´s he saying?"
-Don´t take any advice from me,
but this is what I would do.
-Well, best of luck on that.
And congratulations on Season 2.
-Thank you. Thank you so much.